tish cyrus and billy ray cyrus have
reportedly called it quits after nearly
30 years of marriage with tmz reporting
that tisch filed for divorce last week
with the court in tennessee according to
court documents the pair have not lived
together since february of 2020 with
tisch citing irreconcilable differences
as the grounds for their divorce in
addition tisch is reportedly asking for
all marital assets be divided equally
between the two now this is not the
first time the couple have filed for
divorce in 2010 billy ray filed to end
the marriage but the split was called
off then in 2013 tisch filed for divorce
but it was once again called off soon
after as we know the couple share five
children together including miley and
noah cyrus their youngest child being
over the age of 22 means that custody
will not be a factor in the divorce
proceedings the couple were last seen
publicly together back in 2020 and some
fans speculated about the state of their
marriage over the holidays when billy
ray was not featured in family photos
and videos that miley had posted to
social media